OpenCourseWare is
a web-based program
that will provide free access to
primary materials for virtually
every course at MIT.
The founders of OCW had
a transformative vision
20 years ago of offering
access to materials
from the MIT classroom
openly, freely.
They can learn from them
straight off the website.
They can download them
and carry them around.
They can remix them with
other kinds of materials
mash them up in new ways.
They can share them
with their networks.
We're getting about 22
million visits per year.
We have more than 3
million subscribers
to the OCW YouTube channel.
That makes it the biggest .edu
YouTube channel in the world.
It has captured curious
learners of all stripes
from around the world.
Several thousand MIT faculty
have shared materials
from more than 2,500 courses.
We're sharing materials not just
from the science, technology,
engineering, and math
courses and the management
courses that MIT
is most famous for,
but also from the incredible
richness of our humanities
and social sciences.
The impact of OCW in opening
learning for millions
around the world is multiplied
by the role of educators
elsewhere.
When they take
materials from OCW
and repurpose them and
use them and make them
part of their own teaching,
for each one educator that
does that, there are
dozens or hundreds
more people for whom the
opportunities to learn
are opened up.
It takes resources to do
what we do at OpenCourseWare.
It takes a lot of people and
time and energy and money
to cover the full
curriculum at MIT.
We're right in the middle of
launching the program for OCW's
third decade.
We're delighted that
we have now rolled
out its next-generation
platform.
It's mobile friendly.
It has much better search tools.
What we teach it at
MIT changes with time.
How we teach changes with time.
And now we have a
new platform that
will allow us to keep
the content of OCW
current and vibrant
into the future.
Knowledge should be
free, and especially
knowledge that comes from
leading institutions,
institutions with the most
privilege behind them.
To give that back to
the world has never
been more important than it is.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So many of the challenges
that the world is facing
require the development, the
application, the testing,
the refinement of new
forms of knowledge.
We firmly believe
that a world in which
the educational attainment
of millions of people
has been elevated will
be a better world.
This is making a difference.
[MUSIC PLAYING]